wang chao est quand même c'est la
rentrée et malheureusement le clip 19
n'a pas disparu pire que cela depuis le
mois de juillet le virus semble à
nouveau se propager un rythme
exponentiel
alors il faut faire attention à ce genre
de graff qui ne tiennent compte que des
cas de covile 19 confirmé en effet
contrairement à ce qu'il se passait en
mars
honda est désormais beaucoup plus
d'individus suspects ce qui fait que le
nombre de cas effectif du coc vite 19
est aujourd'hui sans doute beaucoup plus
faibles qu'en mars dernier
néanmoins la trajectoire exponentielle
de la progression du virus depuis plus
d'un mois suggère très vivement que le
taux de reproduction effectif
rt est aujourd'hui nettement supérieur à
1 or comme on l'a vu au début de cette
série rt supérieur ou égal à 1 c'est pas
cool vraiment pas cool
bref même si en ce moment même le coc
vite 19 n'est pas dévastateur notamment
car il affecte surtout les jeunes pour
l'instant tant que rt est supérieur à 1
il ya de quoi vraiment être extrêmement
inquiet sur la situation sanitaire dans
les semaines et les mois à venir
d'autant qu'on risque de se retrouver
beaucoup plus souvent dans des lieux
clos mal aérée vu que l'hiver approche
à
munchhouse conneries dans ce contexte il
est critique de se préparer dès
aujourd'hui est de faire tout ce qui
peut être fait pour réduire
drastiquement les risques divers
désastreux penser notamment a bien
effectué tous les gestes barrière dont
on a déjà beaucoup parlé comme la
distanciation physique le port de
masques et bien sûr du lavage de mains
[Musique]
le temps
ça
[Musique]
mais aujourd'hui je vais insister
chose que vous pouvez faire dans les
semaines à venir à savoir vous vacciner
contre la grippe pour vous protéger mais
aussi et surtout pour protéger les
autres alors pour être clair je préfère
souligner dès à présent le fait que le
vaccin contre la grippe ne vous
protégera pas contre locaux vides 19
mêmes a priori ça ne vous posera
absolument pas contre le coc vide 19 du
coup ce n'est pas parce que vous êtes
vacciné contre la grippe qui vous faut
baisser votre garde contre locaux vides
19 en particulier ne soyez pas surpris
d'attraper le qu'ovide 19 après avoir
été vacciné contre la grippe
malheureusement contre le coc vide 19 à
moins d'un vaccin très sûr et très
efficace dont la sécurité et
l'efficacité semble difficile à garantir
dans un avenir proche il n'y a
il n'y aura pas de solution miracle il
n'y a aucune idée où aucune molécule
simple pour soigner d'un coup d'un seul
ou pour faire disparaître tout à coup
cette terrible maladie
tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est combiné
plein de solutions complémentaires pour
réduire autant que possible les risques
malheureusement combattre le coc vite 19
c'est compliqué et pourtant il nous faut
le combattre
wang km
la raison pour laquelle il semble
important que chacun d'entre nous se
vaccinent contre la grippe c'est pour
éviter ce que certains épidémiologistes
appelle la twin d'amy à savoir une
double épidémie djokovic 19 et de clips
pour commencer même s'il ya encore
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur l'effet
d'une double infection par le virus
arth-goldau dulko vide et le virus de la
grippe il faut s'attendre à ce que ce ne
soit pas très chouette et dans le pire
cas on peut imaginer qu'une double
infection sera très dangereuse y compris
pour des individus a priori peu
vulnérable bref si vous pouvez vous
éviter le risque d'une double infection
qu'ovide grippe
autant le faire et pour y arriver il ya
une solution qui n'est ni dangereuse ni
cher
le vaccin contre la grippe est très
sécurisé et coûte moins de 10 euros
mais comme toujours il est important a
insisté sur le fait que le vaccin ne
protège pas seulement et vaccinés on y
reviendra plus en détail dans quelques
instants
le vaccin vous permet surtout de réduire
drastiquement vos risque de transmettre
le virus de la grippe à vos proches en
particulier des proches plus vulnérables
que vous ainsi vacciner votre enfant
contre la grippe
c'est aussi protéger vos parents et puis
et peut-être surtout se vacciner contre
la grippe
c'est aussi protéger votre communauté et
notamment envoh médecin vous aide
soignant et vos compatriotes qui eux
auront besoin de leurs soins en effet
l'un des gros risques d'une pandémie
comité 19
c'est une surcharge hospitalière or
l'hiver les hôpitaux sont habituellement
déjà davantage remplies notamment à
cause du virus de la grippe réduire
l'épidémie de grippe c'est aussi réduire
le risque de surcharge hospitalière et
toutes ses conséquences comme
l'impossibilité de tester tous les
suspects les risques d'infection à
l'hôpital ou encore le risque de
décision de confinement avec toutes les
répercussions inquiétantes qui
l'accompagnent et dont on a déjà
beaucoup parlé
enfin éviter la double épidémie c'est
aussi éviter des frayeurs pour des
milliers voire des centaines de milliers
de foyers
en effet comme certains symptômes du
comité this n'a fait de la grippe sont
similaires
il risque d'y avoir beaucoup de familles
inquiètes pour les leurs si certains des
leurs développent de tels symptômes
le climat actuel il est critique de
soigner notre santé mentale et ceci
inclut le fait d'éviter des frayeurs et
des inquiétudes en s'immunise en contre
de nombreux risques
malheureusement s'il est très sécure
lisez le vaccin contre la grippe n'est
pas parfaitement efficace
on estime que son efficacité était entre
40 et 60% avec beaucoup d'incertitudes
qui dépendent notamment dé souche
dominante
imaginons que cet hiver cette efficacité
soit 2 50%
est ce que cela suffira pour réduire l'
immunité de groupe pour répondre à ces
questions je vous rappelle une équation
fondamental de l'épidémiologie le taux
de reproduction effectif
rt est égal au taux de reproduction de
base 0 x l'infraction d'individus
susceptibles d'attraper et de diffuser
la maladie est multiplié par l'effet des
gestes barrières on estime le taux de
reproduction de base de la grippe à
quelque chose entre haut disons 1,2 et
1,4
disons 1,33 pour cet hiver un plan
maintenant f la fraction de la
population vaccinée contre la grippe et
alpha l'effet des gestes barrières
le taux de reproduction effectif rt est
alors rt est égal à alpha x 1 - f x 50 %
x 0 ou le 50 % ici correspond à
l'efficacité du vaccin contre la grippe
comme on l'a vu dans un autre épisode de
la série pour que la grippe ne devienne
pas une épidémie il faut avoir rt en
dessous de 1
ce qui revient à exiger à la fois un
mois elles divisées par 2 inférieures à
1 sur herbe 0 qui est égal à 0,75
en l'absence des gestes barrières ou
n'auraient alpha est égal à 1 pour
éviter la pandémie
il nous faut alors avoir f et égale à 2
x 1 - 0,75 qui est égale à 50%
autrement dit si on ne fait pas gaffe et
si la moitié de la population est
vaccinée alors vous pourrez éviter une
épidémie de grippe mais cela risque
d'être juste
il suffit que le vaccin soit un poil
moins efficace que prévu ou que la
grippe de 2020 soit un poil plus
contagieuse que d'habitude pour que
l'épidémie de grippe partent de façon
exponentielle
pour être vraiment tranquille il serait
utile de vacciner une plus grande
proportion de la population ainsi que de
prendre soin des gestes barrières
ainsi avec alpha est égal à 80% et f est
égale à 70 % honoraires t est égal à 0,7
et là on aura fait vraiment de notre
mieux pour éviter double
épidémie
malheureusement l'année qui
annonce délicate du point de vue de la
santé publique en particulier dans les
mois qui viennent on risque d'assister à
des épidémies de kovy de 19 et de grippe
ce qui conduirait à une dangereuse tune
d'amy dans ce contexte il semble urgent
de faire tout ce qui peut être fait pour
réduire les risques de double épidémie
prendre le vaccin antigrippal est
certainement ce que chacun d'entre nous
peut faire facilement donc pour protéger
vous vos proches et votre communauté
je vous invite à penser à vous vacciner
une soluce commun en fait il y a déjà
plusieurs mois
l'académie nationale de médecine
écrivaient les incertitudes sur la
survenue d'une deuxième vague de
l'épidémie de cofidis 9 et sur l'ampleur
de la prochaine grippe saisonnière doit
faire envisager le scénario
catastrophique dans lequel la
conjonction des deux épidémies
entraînerait un engorgement des services
de réanimation et un nouveau pic de
surmortalité l'académie nationale de
médecine recommande d'initier une
campagne d'information et de grande
ampleur clip échos vite 19 pour
sensibiliser la population aux risques
d'une co épidémie bon bah voilà la vidéo
que vous êtes en train de regarder
c'est le résultat de mon envie d'écouter
et de suivre les recommandations de
l'académie nationale de médecine
je vous invite à partager la vidéo à
votre tour pour sensibiliser vous aussi
vos proches et votre entourage à
l'importance du vaccin antigrippal ainsi
qu'à l'importance des gestes barrières
histoire de bien vous protéger et
surtout de protéger vos proches